[Applauso]
buonasera buonasera a tutti
quando mi avete chiamato io non sono
stato un grandissimo studente come molti
sanno per cui mi sono dato a cercare la
detenzione da dizionario di che cosa è
tradizione religiosa innovazione per cui
leggendo le due definizioni tradizione è
il complesso delle memorie notizie e
testimonianze trasmesse da una
generazione all'altra mentre innovazione
l'introduzione di sistemi e criteri
nuovi in economia a voi c'è le parlano
di innovazione di prodotto e innovazione
di processo per cui mi sono chiesto come
riuscirò a comunicare un l'innovazione
che in un'azienda che nata nel 1865 è
riuscita non sono circa 152 anni di
viaggio ad arrivare nello spazio perché
poggi noi forniamo tessuti alla nasa per
gli astronauti delle missioni della
navicella spaziale ai ss
è un viaggio quello che vi racconterò
oggi un viaggio che lo diviso in cinque
tappe in realtà potevano essere di più
ma ho solo 18 minuti di tempo per cui
dovuto sentite darla in cinque tappe
sarà è un viaggio che probabilmente
apparire abbastanza strano un po
sconnesso una tappa all'altra ma è per
vedrete che alla fine legheremo tutto
tutto questo viaggio queste tappe si
legheranno con un filo
ovviamente di lana e si parte dal
da questa immagine questa immagine è
l'immagine del come era l'azienda
governata fino 1998 esattamente il 24
giugno del 1998
la nuova generazione viene invitata ad
entrare il bor di famiglia nel consiglio
di amministrazione scusate della
successore renda per noi è stato un
momento estremamente importante perché
venivamo effettivamente come posso dire
invitati a partecipare a il consiglio in
cui si decidevano le strategie aziendali
per me particolare è stato un momento
estremamente importante ero talmente
emozionato che è stato comprami l'abito
come quando uno va l'abito della festa
per presentarmi in questo consiglio
amministrazione
entriamo un'atmosfera come potete
immaginare abbastanza formale si legge
la relazione di bilancio chiuso alla
chiusura del relazione di bilancio si
discute due ore
dell'orto della nonna con anche
un'intensa e dialettica tra fratelli di
quel consiglio amministrazione ricordo
solo che i pomodori costavano di più
severo portati dagli stati uniti a
biella piuttosto che prodotti nell'otto
di mia nonna
e allora più è cominciata una
riflessione che mi chiedo ma io sto
all'interno dell'amministrazione di
aziende importante un'azienda che andava
molto bene un'azienda che aveva successo
mi sono reso conto che la strategia e le
decisioni vengano prese durante la
patinata erano cinque fratelli c'è una
confidenza tale che era necessario non
era necessario un momento importante per
per decidere quali era il futuro
dell'azienda
la prima riflessione che mi è venuta in
mente nei nostri mie cugine che
difficilmente saremmo stati in grado di
ripetere questo tipo di soluzione perché
la confidenza tra cugine diverse perché
i rapporti sono totalmente diversi ma
soprattutto perché il mondo cambia si
evolve e questo il nuovo consiglio
d'amministrazione della successo in rete
è un profilo instagram di un nostro
consigliere è un'immagine completamente
diversa dove c'è maggiore informalità
all'interno di un momento invece molto
più formale prima era un'immagine molto
formale e vivevamo una croce
amministrazione invece molto informale
questo è un consiglio amministrazione
che non è più un consiglio ovviamente
preceduto solo da membri della famiglia
ma anzi i membri della famiglia sono in
minoranza dove ci sono persone che sono
stanti amate per la loro competenza
c'è l'ex direttore marketing di yoox c'è
un professore della bocconi
c'è una una manager una top manager di
microsoft italia che oggi direttore
delle vendite del western europe
questo perché oggi noi siamo di fronte
delle sfide dei cambiamenti incredibili
stiamo vivendo
cambiamenti legati all digital
innovation legati alla intelligenza
artificiale al machine learning dove le
competenze difficilmente si possono
tutte queste competenze si possono
trovare all'interno di una famiglia
pensare che una famiglia abbia tutte
queste conoscenze e abbastanza nel
presuntuoso per cui s'è creato un
modello decisionale diverso si è creato
una situazione dove l'interazione con
queste persone con queste competenze si
mischiavano con quella che l'unica cosa
che noi riteniamo importante trasmettere
tra il passato e il futuro che sono i
valori i valori
l'unica cosa che credo aver imparato in
tutti questi anni sono le cose al sole
fondamento di un'azienda quelli devono
rimanere sempre semplicemente adattati a
situazioni diverse
il secondo step del nostro viaggio della
nuova zelanda
qui facciamo un altro salto spazio
temporale andiamo nel 1992 nel 1992 mio
padre mio cugino deciso di comprare una
fattoria e nuova zelanda con un piano
strategico studiato a tavolino
lunghissimo praticamente mio padre
chiama il mio zio dice c'è una fattoria
che costa come un appartamento a lui
opera new york la fattoria 10.000 ettari
e mi oggetto compra la comprate adesso
crociere facciale sto fattoria in un
momento in cui i nostri clienti
tendenzialmente tendenziali meno scusate
i nostri concorrenti tendenzialmente
aprivano shop
noi vi ho comprato shaper per anni mi è
sembrato che la strategia non fosse
proprio quella corretta
ma tant'è che i banali comincia un
percorso ovviamente noi non conoscevamo
questo tipo di attività non sapevano che
cosa a significare significava allevare
delle pecore per cui ci siamo
semplicemente
guardati attorno abbiamo guardato quelli
che arrivavano le pecore aveva delle
fattorie migliori di noi e abbiamo
cominciato a fare conoscenza intorno e
quindi i nostri vicini poi ci siamo
allargati in tutta la nuova zelanda
dopodiché ci siamo anche spostati in
australia cercando di capire cercando di
conoscerli che cosa abbiamo fatto in
realtà in tutti questi anni noi tutti
questi anni abbiamo raccolto dati
abbiamo raccolto con infinita di dati di
allevatori di fattorie che avevano i
migliori metodi di allevamento di più il
più sostenibile e più green di quelli
che più qualitativi e difatti abbiamo
oggi un valore che è importante
soprattutto in questo periodo nel nostro
mondo in modo la moda che la
tracciabilità
secondo terzo step invece saltiamo 2002
nel 2002
noi giovani
eravamo lenti nelle nostre forze
volevamo rivoluzionare il tessile
vedevamo le possibilità di cambiare di
poter dire la nostra di dare un pò è
stato un po il periodo in cui le
generazioni ad una generazione giovane
sente di poter dare e dire la sua e
ovviamente cerca di dire qualcosa di
diverso rispetto a quella precedente per
cui nasce un progetto abbiamo dagli zii
che i tempi erano ancora gestivano
ancora loro tutti l'azienda la
generazione precedente andiamo a
proporre un progetto rivoluzionario
tingere tutti i prodotti e tutti i
nostri tessuti con coloranti provenienza
naturale
gli chiediamo di investire 250 mila euro
per aprire un laboratorio creano un
abortivo di certamente non è un'azienda
inserire un ingegnere chimico e partiamo
partiamo cominciamo a contattare
università cominciamo
a ripoli tecnico o la normale di pisa
città studi all'università di bologna
arriviamo alla messa di sassa universo
di sassari che sembrava verso una
conoscenza incredibile i curanti
naturali ci informano che siamo
assolutamente indietro rispetto a quello
che è la realtà sarda che qualcuno
parlava della sardegna effettivamente
sardegna davanti
guardate che qui in sardegna c'è
un'industria che vige da anni con
coloranti naturali ha vinto anche un
premio europeo di è stata finanziata
dalla comunità europea carica tutta la
squadra sull'aereo vai a sassari prende
la macchina vai di un paese che credo si
chiama non torno più
non mi ricordo bene chiaro mezzo alla
sardegna arriviamo troviamo un capanno
con la macchina di tito rialza così
costruita da il nostro vicino di casa
coach ora quindi due chilometri
dov'eravamo è una villetta nuova di
zecca
siamo anche il primo persone che aveva
avuto che forse si era costruito la
villa con i fondi europei di coloranti
naturali nulla ma non ci arrendiamo
torniamo indietro partiamo germania
francia giriamo tutta l'europa
alla fine ce la facciamo alla fine
riusciamo a trovare tutte le sostanze
per spingere tutti i nostri prodotti con
coloranti naturali e li fallisce il
progetto
perché ci siamo dimenticati di tenere
conto dell'impatto che avrebbe potuto
avere nell'industria e nell'agricoltura
con il nostro progetto perché metta fine
al l'industria del mondo della moda di
bender praticamente da due colori blu e
nero il blu lo faremo fatto con l'indaco
che avremmo dovuto comprare il 70 per
cento della produzione mondiale di
indaco perché l'efficienza del colorante
naturale non è quella del curante
chimico e per il nero era stato uno
studio enorme disposta avremmo discusso
bosco più disboscato la foresta
equatoriale perché lo ricavano dalla
patch di un albero in brasile per cui
abbiamo pensato che decide che la loggia
un film interpretato da di caprio che
raccontava la sua storia a coloro che
distruggevano la foresta equatoriale voi
immaginate poi quando si adatta del
muse'e mio padre a raccontargli che il
puntata spese che erano fatti ormai a
della sardegna
l'aveva buttata li ha in realtà abbiamo
imparato da questo fallimento abbiamo
imparato che ogni innovazione ogni
processo innovativo e deve essere
valutato per l'impatto che porta ed
alice celato un altro tipo di approccio
abbiamo modificato il nostro approccio
non ci siamo arresi abbiamo soltanto
cambiato direzione
ci siamo resi conto che una società come
quella di oggi dove il benessere e il
peggior nemico della sostenibilità
avremmo dovuto lavorare per ridurre il
nostro impatto ognuno di noi e ognuno di
voi in sala si sveglia al mattino e
consuma di più di quello che è
necessario consumo più acqua consuma più
energia con sua più luce proprio tutto
la pulita la stessa cosa l'industria la
stessa cosa per cui abbiamo cominciato a
pensare di ridurre il nostro impatto
ambientale fare tutta una serie
d'iniziative fare tutta una serie di
investimenti che ci sarebbero serviti a
ridurre questo impatto ma non tanto
perché ritenevamo che fosse giusto e
avremmo voluto salvare il mondo perché
ci siamo resi conti con l'esperienza
precedente che quando penso sarà il
mondo rischio di distruggerlo
ma perché è la questione di
competitività perché se un domani la
terra non aumenta la sua superficie e
non credo che sia in grado di farlo ma
aumenta il numero di popolazione e della
storia come ci raccontava lui prima da
quando decide di prendere una bistecca
che trasformarla poi quello che vuole
migliorare vuole vivere meglio e questo
vivere meglio ha un impatto per cui per
essere competitivi nel futuro deve
essere più sostenibile perché vuol dire
che riduci le piccole sprechi riduce le
risorse che ti servono e quindi siamo
andati a cercare quello che oggi è un
tema molto contemporanea che la
sostenibilità
siamo l'unica azienda con la
certificazione europea che obbliga le
aziende a ridurre l'impatto ogni due
anni
altro prendiamo la navicella altro salto
spazio temporale abbiamo nel 2008 prima
della crisi prima della crisi lehman
brothers
mi chiamano dall'ufficio di shanghai noi
abbiamo un ufficio shanghai di sole
donne il giusto per rassicurare luisa mi
dicono guarda c'è una tua vecchia amica
che era studiato a biella che lavora per
un cliente che un modello di business
strano fa abiti su misura online
ho fatto una di quelle risate anche un
po risentirle oggi po presuntuose questi
cosa fanno abiti online sommati abiti su
misura online non sono però la ragazza
era anche molto carino detto un guado
trovarla e vediamo di salutarla la
ritrovo mi racconta con entusiasmo
questo nuovo modello di business deve
invita a conoscere il suo titolare in
particolare
il ragazzo piccolino di origine malese e
kehl e lo vado incontra in questo grande
magazzino a shanghai vuoto completamente
vuoto vede un ragazzo si avvicina da
lontano ovviamente come da un buon
biellese nel mondo del tessile dello
giudichi come vestito per l'abbinamento
io fi wi fi proprio screening lo vedo
amici di come l'avrebbe sciancrato le
spalle sono giuste dell'abbinamento
altro ragazzo tutto sommato a del gusto
mentre si avvicina mi rendo conto che
aveva l'abito confezionato al rovescio
si è preso il tessuto che era
confezionato per essere emerso in un
certo modo l'ha confessato il rovescio
qui da un punti sta qualitativo
assolutamente assurdo cioè non era
possibile che questo abito fosse
confezionato così è come prevedere non
so una pizza e mangiarla rovescio lungo
cuoce alla rovescia non ha senso
pellicole su questo faccio due ore con
questo guardo mi racconto beh dopo due
ore ragazzi ho capito che non capivo
nulla io perché mi ero reso conto che a
40 anni avevo incontrato un ragazzo che
ne aveva 20 28 quindi avevo 12 anni
indifferenza ma io guardavo il futuro
con gli occhi di mio padre e mio zio che
avevano 70 75 la sua vera forza è
proprio che non capiva niente per non
capiva niente di stoffa non capiva
niente di abiti perché nessuno di noi
con lo storico con la conoscenza che
aveva prima
altrove mai potuto immaginare di fare
qualcosa del genere
e allora mi sono reso conto che forse
avrei dovuto cambiare il modo di pensare
avrei dovuto guardarle o le cose in
maniera diversa con un po più di
ignoranza ma non nel senso negativo
della parola ignoranza nel senso proprio
del dizionario cioè che meglio pignori
certe cose perché sono altrimenti non le
fai
torno a casa qui ho messo la parola
incoscienza o in realtà era un po più
ignoranza
secondo me e decidiamo di trovare e
supportare due ragazzi che avevano le
stesse caratteristiche non capivano
niente di stoffa e gli abiti tuttora
sono le stesse condizioni e del motivo
per cui sta funzionando ma però
decidiamo anche di guardare il nostro
modello di business con occhi diversi e
cominciamo a farci le stesse domande che
siano fatti fino a ieri ma cercando di
dare una risposta completamente diverse
ci siamo chiesti che cosa eravamo chi
eravamo cosa sapevamo fare
avete visto siamo allevatori
trasformatori noi siamo esperti di lana
e come esperti l'hanno pensavamo di
vendere tessuti in un certo modo ma non
certo un certo mondo e abbiamo deciso di
dire vabbè proviamo a mettere giù queste
caratteristiche della lana delle
caratteristiche sue naturali che sono
traspirabile terrore per mo regolatrice
elastica insomma una è una fibra
performante nasce il progetto revolution
che modo nuovo di pensare la stoffa con
diciamo un unico obiettivo pensare a un
tessuto che dia una performance per cui
oggi se andate sul mercato e chiedete
che cosa deve avere un tessuto
innovativo deve avere la tracciabilità
perché oggi tutti vogliono sapere da
dove arriva il prodotto deve essere
sostenibile deve essere performante deve
aver dei valori sotto l'azienda che lo
produce e un po di incoscienza per poter
immaginare qualcosa di diverso
oggi la possibilità di dei tessuti
performanti sono infinite vendiamo
abbigliamento marino alla nautica
all'urban were ai caschi perché il
tessuto della rana dovete sapere che
assorbe i cattivi odori al mondo delle
scarpe al mondo della montagna ma
soprattutto alla nasa ed eccoci arrivati
nello spazio ricordiamoci sempre qui la
connessione alla domanda che mi ero
fatto in his all'inizio che se tieni
sempre la tradizione del cuore e apri la
mente un'innovazione tutti voi potete
augurarmi di fare un viaggio verso il
futuro
grazie
[Applauso]